tapez votre fiction là il répond
paillettes avec notre journal essabah
alors on va aller le retrouver alesi a
lésé c'est en compagnie d'alexis dominer
du cercle donc qui vient tout juste de
déclarer vainqueur dans lac saint jean
avec six essais fébrile en début de
soirée vous attendiez nbc russie à
l'époque trois qu'on vous attendent tout
le monde s'attendait notre série thief
d'un masque un gain assez convaincant à
poitiers votre nouveau produit pas ce
qu'on appelle en une équipe incroyable
accès les gens une équipe électorale
incroyable les bénévoles etc royal peut
remercier les gens l'accès aux gens
n'aiment pas confiance
j'ai travaillé quand rayant pour le
prouver qu'ils ont eu raison d'elle pas
dans la région depuis deux ans et demi
seulement
l'apprenti je sais la dette ont
considéré connu allemands ont changé
père ancien maire sortant surface assez
joué ça les démange me philippe meilhac
dassa le pen campagne pleine campagne
nomme ici dans l'axé et g je suis très
heureux de ça je pense que sa tribu en
trop douce et la performance du chef du
parti bien entendu mais aussi à l'équipe
régionale dans la mise en place à la
mine plateforme régionale est le seul à
le faire évidemment ça touche
directement les enjeux les gens donc oui
je pense que les deux combinés offert
sorte qu'à berlin une belle victoire de
soi et je salue mon père soit là aussi
vous savez pas ce que je disais je
disais plus tôt aujourd'hui que vous
espérez faire un prénom aujourd'hui
alexis bruel duceppe
vous aviez connu dans la région beaucoup
comme étant le fils de gilles duceppe
vous êtes désormais le député de
lac-saint-jean félicitations et j'avais
de passer votre corps qui mordent envie
de vous parler
non bellot mr lavaud monga écoute tu
disais on y vient de dire tu étais le
fils de gilles duceppe moi j'étais le
fils de jean duceppe qui est devenu mon
père maintenant je veux on va m'appeler
le père d'alexis ii men avons nous aussi
je t'aime beaucoup mais là bon ok elle a
commencé sa soirée
[Applaudissements]
le thème c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
métier c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
métier là ce sont des vrais moments
c'est de l'émotion c'est des histoires
humaines ses campagnes électorales
vous avez un exemple mais tous les
candidats et candidates ont des mamans
des papas qui sont dans tous leurs états
qui leur disent pauvre toi ce sera
prochaine x ou y est on a gagné et c'est
ça une soirée assez ma petite fille
simone que la double nationalité
préférez vous l'avais déjà dit c'est
simone qui le présentait lors des
assemblées
elle a 8 ans qu'un président de cette là
où on prépare on prépare déjà la paix